hey just before we get cracking with
today's video I've got to say there's a
lot of Russian pronunciations in here I
am locking them up when I can but I
don't always get them hundred-percent
right I apologize ahead of time if you
want to have a go at me well that's what
the comments are for right okay let's
crack on during the Bolshevik Revolution
the Romanov dynasty was killed after
over a 100 year reign of Russia the
bodies of the parents and all five
children were laid out on the grounds
but when the corpses were later moved
and given a proper burial the bodies of
the son Alexei and the princess
Anastasia were missing
this gave the Russian people hope that
at least two of these innocent children
managed to play dead
long enough in order to escape several
years later a young woman was admitted
to a mental hospital in Germany there
were scars all over her body and she
clearly suffered some traumatic events
but her mind had blocked out the painful
memories she couldn't even remember her
own name the only clue about where she
came from was the fact that she spoke
with a Russian accent months later a
Russian patient was admitted to that
same hospital and she immediately began
to kneel in front of this young girl she
claimed that she recognized her as the
missing princess Anastasia but who was
this young woman was she really the
long-lost princess or would this go down
as one of the biggest frauds in all of
history
[Music]
Anastasia Romanov was born in 1901 to
tsar nicholas ii and his wife Tsarina
Alexandra Feodorovna a proper title was
Grand Duchess but no one ever addressed
the young girl with this proper title in
her daily life she had three older
sisters or gonorrhea and Tatiana her
younger brother Alexei was meant to
ascend to the throne someday the
Romanoff children were the first Royals
to have such an extensive collection of
family photographs there are hundreds of
pictures and videos of their family
vacations and playing games on the
palace grounds it was easy to see that
they lived a carefree life their
pictures were publicized all over Russia
and they became the darlings of the
country Anastasia was an extremely
energetic toddler who had a bubbly
personality she was very intelligent so
she grew bored of her tutors lessons
very quickly she was a tomboy and she
enjoyed playing outside far more than
doing ladylike activities with her
sisters she was described as clumsy and
was always climbing on something or
running around somewhere she seemed to
have an endless amount of energy
according to some of her cousins and
ladies-in-waiting Anastasia is bored and
manifested in some terrible ways she
would entertain herself by playing
pranks on people and her cousins called
her evil and one of the servants called
her a terrorist she trips her servants
in the hallway climbed up trees and
refused to come down and hit rocks
inside of snowballs she would often
cheat during games and she lied a lot to
get herself out of trouble at one time a
monk named grigori rasputin became the
spiritual advisor of the Romanov family
sorry nor alexandra wholeheartedly
believed that he had magical powers that
healed her son Alexei who was suffering
from hemophilia Rasputin was able to
heal him from the brink of death because
of this she listened to his advice and
gave him free rein in the Royal Palace
Anastasia
may or may not have realized it but her
father Nicholas had a problem with drugs
in one of his diary entries he wrote
about waking up with a stuffy nose and
planning to fix it by snorting cocaine
back then though cocaine was actually
prescribed by doctors as medication so
it didn't hold the same stigma that it
does today while she did not take
recreational drugs Tsarina Alexandra was
described as being anxious and
high-strung Anastasia commented that her
mother barely ever indulged in coffee or
wine because she had
stomach she was also incredibly
spiritual and often went to mystics to
help make decisions about her day-to-day
life Rasputin was also pretty famous for
using morphine cocaine and opium on a
regular basis some historians believe
that the closer he got to the Tsar and
Tsarina the more the couple became
dependent on the drugs and guidance of
the fanatical religion that Rasputin was
introducing them to after witnessing the
terrible things that drugs did to the
adults in her life Anastasia became
obsessed with clean eating and natural
remedies
she spoke against drug use and became a
vegetarian every time she was sick she
would throw a fit refusing to take any
medication because she didn't want to be
like Rasputin and her father servants
noted that Rasputin was given a little
too much access to the children in 1910
one of the nannies was particularly
disturbed about the fact that the monk
was often witnessed with four girls when
they were in their nightgowns he had the
freedom to enter the children's nursery
whenever he wanted that's in year one of
the other governess is claimed that
Rasputin's raped her she tried to tell
the Tsarina but sadly the Tsarina was so
brainwashed to by Rasputin that she
refused to believe the governess the
girls they were growing older the eldest
daughters were already teenagers and
Anastasia was nine years old one of the
other servants believed the governess's
story about the rape the parents of the
children were far too preoccupied with
their own issues so this lonely tried to
keep Rasputin away from the children
the girls they were very naive and did
not see any issue with him coming to
visit them at night they called him a
friends and when they told Serena
Alexandre that the nanny was trying to
keep them out of the nursery at night
she was fired according to the children
Rasputin was simply visiting to tell
them bedtime stories and help them say
their prayers back in his hometown
Rasputin actually did have children of
his own so it's always possible that he
was acting on fatherly instinct but his
reputation of being a sexual deviance
would be enough for anyone to be worried
after the nanny was fired she told
everyone she knew about the story this
sparked a rumor that Rasputin had free
reign to visit the princesses at night
in a sexual way there is no evidence
that Rasputin ever actually abused the
Romanov children but of course we'll
never really know what happens
closed doors however it was around this
time that Tsar Nicholas ordered Rasputin
to leave some Petersburg when World War
one first began Anastasia was only 13
years old her mother and sisters were
old enough to volunteer as nurses for
the Red Cross she did her duty by
playing pool and chess with the soldiers
and entertained people with her wild
energy and laughter as a teenager
Anastasia used her acting talents for
good though what seems like
mean-spirited pranks that she played in
her childhood actually ended up being a
love for comedy her family and members
of the staff would often put on their
own plays and performances according to
witnesses Anastasia was naturally
hilarious and did everyone laughing so
hard that they had peers in their eyes
sometimes she would burst out funny
faces when the camera was trying to
capture a candid moment of her and her
sisters in every difficult situation
Anastasia was always the one to fix it
and always the one to make everyone
around her smile now after the war
Russia began suffering a terrible
depression people were starving men had
died during the war and people
desperately needed help many people
viewed the royal family as being part of
the problem their reputation for bad
decision making with Rasputin certainly
didn't help either and basically the
short of it is that communism took hold
by the time Anastasia turned 16 the
Romanov family was placed under house
arrest by the Bolsheviks
the reminyl family were ordered to leave
their car cellent were put under house
arrest they were moved from place to
place and their last residence was a
place called a patty of house even in
these dark moments Anastasia was still
trying to make everyone laugh and smile
it was noted that she adjusted the best
to that new life of captivity one of the
guards told a story of Anastasia trying
to open a window for some fresh air and
they shot at her to keep her from trying
to escape she turned to the guard and
stuck her tongue out Sam the window shut
and walked away even in this awful
situation for her she was fearless
at first Lenin wrote the family was in
captivity and promised that they were
still alive however he soon realized
that as long as the royal bloodline
still existed there would always be a
chance that soldiers loyal to the
Romanovs would try to overthrow him
he decided that the only way for
communism to exist was to execute the
entire family the family was made to
walk down to the basement where a group
of men were ordered to shoot at them
during the execution the gunmen realized
that the daughters were still alive even
after being shot multiple times in the
chest it turns out they were all wearing
corsets that had been lined with Rahl
gemstones and this acted like a
bulletproof vest after this each of the
family members received a shots of the
head to ensure that they actually did
die however some believe that these gem
lined corsets would have been enough for
the gunman to hesitate to kill the two
youngest members of the family at this
point all of the older daughters were
full-grown women but Anastasia and
Alexey were only 13 and 16 years old
they were innocent children and they
didn't deserve to die many people hoped
that the guards took pity on them one of
the men in the firing squad Rudolph
Flaco was originally from Austria and he
was staying in Russia as a prisoner of
war as a foreigner he had no loyalty to
the imperial family and was ordered to
serve the Bolsheviks he claimed that he
pulled over the truck when it got stuck
in the mud he could hear a rustling in
the back and when he went to check on
the bodies he discovered that Anastasia
was still alive and he helped her escape
however there were other quotes from
lacquer that indicated the total
opposite was true he was once quoted as
saying that he didn't care about killing
the Romanov family they weren't
relatives of his and he was doing his
duty for the Bolsheviks but this
confession was enough to spark rumours
that Anastasia had
I escaped
[Music]
in 1920 a young woman in Berlin Germany
attempted to jump off a bridge and
commit suicide nearby police officers
saved her life and brought her to a
mental hospital for treatments she was
beautiful and spoke with a thick Russian
accent when the doctors asked her who
she was she replied that she didn't know
there were scars all over her body
including a triangle shaped indentation
in her foot and deep lacerations on her
back it was clear that she had survived
some sort of horrific trauma and her
brain had completely shut down every
night she would wake up screaming to her
nightmares the memories they were simply
too painful for her to recall when she
was awake but at night they seemed to
come to her the doctors gave her the
nickname of miss unknown two years later
Miss unknown was still living in a
mental hospital in Germany when a
Russian woman was admitted as a
patient's the woman was shocked and
immediately kneeled in front of the
young women she said that this was the
missing princess Anastasia miss unknown
did not confirm or deny the statement
she had no idea who she actually was and
becoming a princess sounded pretty fine
to her so the doctors this actually made
a lot of sense though miss unknown had
clearly endured something horrific and
it was the answer to a mystery they had
long been trying to solve comparing
photos of both miss unknown and
Anastasia next to one another it is easy
to see why many people believe this to
be true they have the same ears nose and
eyes miss unknown was also the same age
in 1922 newspapers began to claim that
the princess had been found and her
photo was published friends and family
of the Romanovs came from all over the
world to visit her they would ask her
questions that only Anastasia would know
and yet somehow this woman knew many of
the answers the opinion of friends and
family was divided 50/50 while a case
was under investigation she was invited
to stay in castles with reminyl cousins
and several people sent money to her to
help her pay for her expenses
Anastasia's tutor Sidney Gibbs was one
of the most outspoken critics though he
vividly remembered his students
personality no matter how much they
looked the same this woman lacked
Anastasia's wit and her sense of humor
another tutor Pia gorilla agreed they
found the true princess first however
once he spent more time around this
woman he agreed that they were not the
same person she was soft-spoken and
ladylike for relatives who only saw her
when she was on her best
it was easy to imagine that she could be
Anastasia but for people who knew what
she was really like this was an entirely
different person the surviving members
of the royal family met up to discuss
whether or not this woman deserved to
receive the inheritance of the Romanov
family in the end they came to a vote
and decided that there was not enough
evidence to prove that she was the real
Anastasia her supporters were shocked
because they really felt that she was
the true princess
Grand Duchess Xenia Alexandrovna sister
of Tsar Nicholas ii and Anastasia's aunt
wrote that she was outraged by this
decision and that the remaining family
was simply just greedy for the friends
and family who believed her they felt
very sorry for this disowned princess
and wanted to do whatever they could to
help her she lives a life of luxury and
she was given anything she could ever
want she eventually moved to New York
with a woman named Annie Byrd Jennings
where she was able to live in a gorgeous
penthouse she changed her name to Anna
Anderson she met a man named Jack
Monahan who was a history teacher in
Virginia they lived out a very happy
life together in the United States
miss Anderson went to her grave claiming
that she was Grand Duchess Anastasia
after the fall of the Soviet Union in
1991 historians searched for the bodies
of the Romanov family after confirming
their identities through DNA tests with
surviving relatives they were given a
proper burial in the sim Peter and Paul
Cathedral in st. Petersburg and
canonized as Saints in 1998 however the
bodies of Alexei and Anastasia were
missing this was enough to further fuel
the debate so now we have the question
that of course is in your mind and
that's whether Anna Anderson was
actually Anastasia after all this
inspired several movies and plays
including the 1997 animated movie
Anastasia
in 2007 the bones of two human bodies
were found buried in the middle of the
woods inside area one was a male and the
other was female the bones showed signs
of being doused with acid and burned by
fire as well it was finally confirmed
through DNA testing that these were the
missing bodies of Anastasia and Alexi
according to records and forensic
evidence scientists and historians now
believe that the men who killed the
Romanovs attempted to burn the bodies
but started off with the two smallest
Alexi and Anastasia they covered the
bones in sulfuric acid and then set them
on fire when they discovered that this
did not completely destroy the evidence
they decided to move along and bury the
rest of the bodies elsewhere this is why
the two children had been separated from
the rest of their family as for Anna
Anderson she was dead years before the
truth of her identity was revealed it
turns out that she was a polish factory
worker she was married and worked
together with her husband one day a
grenade was tossed into the factory and
exploded she had to witness the love of
her life and several co-workers dying
around her before receiving a severe
head injury
her body was scarred from the shrapnel
of the explosion after recovering from
her wounds she had no family no friends
to help her home she somehow managed to
make it to Germany which is where the
police found her and as they say the
rest is history after revealing the
truth of her identity many people began
to call Anna Anderson a fraud and a liar
she was able to live a life of total
luxury and many consider her to simply
be a very skilled con woman however it's
very possible that in a mental state she
may have actually believed that she was
the real Anastasia before she was
discovered in the mental hospital she
was a young woman who had nothing left
to live for she was ready to take her
own life
but becoming Anastasia gave her an
identity a purpose and a family who
loved her for the people who desperately
needed to regain their faith in humanity
they needed to believe the innocent
children had survived the slaughter in
her own way Anna Anderson gave them a
reason to believe in miracles from what
we know about the real Anastasia she
lived to make people smile if she knew
that her memory and even the mere
possibility of being alive brought so
much hope and joy to so many people she
would surely have been proud so I really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did please do give us a thumbs up
below and don't forget to subscribe
we've got brand new videos just like
this every day of the week if you're
looking for something else right now why
not check out my podcast it's called
brain food you can find it on iTunes or
wherever you get your podcasts just
search one word it's kind of like we do
a longer form look into interesting bits
and pieces from history and the
present-day find a link below
like I say or to search brain food one
word and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]